find the original functions f of X and G
of X such that when they're composed
they give us H of X so what we're gonna
do here is we're going to take a look at
the inner function and the outer
function and that's how we're going to
find out what our original two functions
were so in this example you can see that
2x minus 3 is like our inner function so
what we can say is let's make this the G
of X function so G of X is equal to 2x
minus 3 now the outer function see f of
X that's what we're putting G of X into
is this square root function so we have
f of X is equal to the square root of x
now the nice thing about this is you can
test your functions to see if this works
so you could say well let's see f of G
of X means that I take my G of X
function ok 2x minus 3 and I put it into
my F function so the way that this works
is you know whatever is here in
parentheses goes in place for X on the
right so we have the square root of and
we're putting 2x minus 3 in place of X
and you can see that's giving us back
our original function now you might be
thinking to yourself well Mario isn't
there another way to do this and you're
absolutely right through it there's more
than way to do this I think this is the
easy way just to think about this whole
quantity as an inner function and then
that square root is the outer function
but let's just give you another example
another example would be say for example
that our inner function was G of x
equals 2 ax and let's say that our outer
function was actually the square root of
x minus 3 so now when you compose the
two functions when you put G of X in for
f of X in place of X you're going to get
back to X minus 3 the square root so
more than one way to do it but I like to
think of it keep it simple inner
function outer function let's look at
another example say number 2 here how
would you do this one well here what I'm
thinking is let's make this our inner
function our G of X so we're going to
say G of X is equal to this whole
quantity 3x minus 2 our outer function f
of X is equal to 1 over something right
1 over X again we can check our work
we've got F of G of X G of X this
quantity here is equal to 3x minus 2
and we're putting that into our F
function so our F function is 1 over X
but this is like our new x-value we're
gonna replace X with mmm this quantity
here 3x minus 2 and you can see we're
getting back our original equation for H
of X so that's how you decompose
functions if you want to see more about
composition of functions working forward
check out the video I did right there
and I'll see over in that video